que ce soit d'ailleurs vos territoires
merci merci ben écoutez on va pouvoir
clôturer notre notre table ronde merci à
vous d'avoir été présent et et à ceux
qui sont en visio de nous avoir consacré
un petit moment moi ce que je veux juste
vous rappeler c'est que c'est important
pour nous aussi d'avoir votre regard
spécifique avec vos spécificités de
montagnards ces communes qui ont qui
subissent des variations de population
en très peu de temps selon les saisons
c'est communes qui ont des équipements
très spécifiques à mettre en place aussi
en fonction de ces variations de
population ces communes ou il y a aussi
je pense la responsabilité qui est
décuplée par rapport à une commune
classique ne serait-ce que quand on gère
des stations de ski ou des
établissements thermaux ou de les deux
là on est sur sur des questions de
responsabilité y compris pénales sur des
des communes aussi qui ont des handicaps
liés aux risques au risque majeur au
risque d'inondation de gisement de
terrain et ça c'est c'est important pour
nous aussi de voir que ce ne sont pas
forcément ces responsabilités là qui
sont des freins pour vous et qui vous
empêchent de vous de vous consacrer à
vos communes vous avez juste aussi
parler de de ces deux fameux irritants
que l'on a aujourd'hui avec le zan et
l'eau potable sachez que la semaine
dernière nous avons passé deux
propositions de loi au Sénat sur ces
sujets là proposition de loi de
Jean-Yves roux sur le retour à
l'optionnalité de la compétence eau
potable et assainissement et sur le zan
la proposition de loi blanc l'État qui
qui revient aussi sur une une garantie
rurale de un hectare par commune par
commune donc ça c'est le Sénat essaie de
travailler mais franchement on se sent
pas forcément écouté de l'autre côté la
barrière du Parlement voilà merci en
tout cas à vous et bon retour dans vos
territoires et je salue les
hautes-pyrénéens et l'Ardèche en vis io
merci à tous
merci
[Musique]
bien bonsoir à tous Alors je vais
demander déjà à ceux qui sont en
visioconférence s'ils peuvent brancher
leur caméra et leur micro s'il vous
plaît ça nous facilitera
la Réunion alors mes chers collègues
nous allons passer à cette deuxième
table ronde de cette journée
consacrée aux communautés aux communes
ultramarines
et je salue notre collègue Marie-Laure
finiraort qui est membre du bureau de la
délégation sénatoriale aux outre-mer et
qui remplace au pied levés un petit peu
Stéphane Artano qui n'a pas pu se
libérer pour le président de la
délégation qui n'a pas pu se libérer
pour se joindre à nous et je vous
remercie de représenter la délégation au
sénatoriale aux outre-mer ici cher
collègue alors sans me présente par
visioconférence Monsieur
Eric André qui est premier
vice-président de l'Association des
maires de Guadeloupe et maire de la
commune de vieux fort
monsieur voilà si vous pouviez vous
signaler Monsieur Michel Ange Jérémy
président de l'Association des maires de
Guyane maire de cinéma
ce qui nous a rejoint
il faut brancher votre caméra et votre
micro si vous il est pas là il est pas
encore arrivé monsieur Jean-Claude masse
président de l'Association des communes
et collectivités d'outre-mer ah mais non
maire de Capesterre de Marie-Galante
Guadeloupe
oui
bonjour monsieur monsieur Yannick
Cambrai maire de Saint-Pierre
bonjour
et Monsieur Franck descheverry maire de
Miquelon Langlade
nous a pas encore tout à fait rejoint
peut-être
ah oui il faut que vous branchiez votre
micro et votre caméra si vous pouviez
ça serait bien pour le pour la
retransmission parce que je vous précise
que cette audition est retransmise en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat et
sera aussi disponible à rediffusion
alors merci messieurs de votre présence
je vous remercie de participer à nos
échanges et de nous éclairer sur les
problématiques
ultramarines et l'avenir qui se dessine
selon vous pour les communes et les élus
que vous représentez dans les
collectivités ultramarines et rappeler
rapidement le cadre de cette mission qui
a été installé il y a quelques semaines
une mission qui comprend une vingtaine
de sénateurs que je préside et notre
rapporteur Mathieu Darnaud sénateur de
l'Ardèche en charge d'animer les débats
et de et de
faire ce rapport qui sera remis début
juillet après que nous ayons fait un
état des lieux et ce que nous ayons pu
auditionner toutes les personnes qui
vous sembler importante à auditionner
donc vous faites partie de celle là et
je vous je passe sans plus tarder la
parole à notre rapporteur
merci même la présidente Carrère salut
et l'ensemble des collègues et
particulièrement nos deux collègues du
yannet et puis ça lui est l'ensemble des
mères qui
nous font l'honneur de leur présence en
visioconférence je veux pas allonger le
propos simplement l'intérêt pour nous on
vient de prendre de l'attitude puisqu'on
était avec des mères de montagnes de
métropole maintenant on est sur la
problématique ultramarine donc la
volonté de cette mission c'est
d'entendre absolument tout les maires de
tous les territoires de France en
mettant l'accent sur leur singularité et
quand je dis singularité les communes
d'outre-mer ont des singularités très
fortes nous étions avec le président
l'archet en Guadeloupe et en Martinique
il y a de cela deux mois nous avons eu
l'occasion de toucher du doigt ces
problématiques et la singularité de ces
problématiques et puis pour être déjà
rendu en Guyane notamment
c'est très bien la la complexité que
revêt le fait d'avoir des communes avec
des territoires communaux alors je ne
pense pas que ça m'arrive pas sous la
parce que Marie pas sous la c'est grand
comme trois départements
métropolitains mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
des singularités toutes toutes parties
particulières et c'est aussi un peu cela
que nous attendons de de vous pour
parler bien sûr des points dont qui ne
manqueront pas de faire convergence quel
que soit le territoire d'élection quel
que soit la commune de France
hexagonale ou mais ou
ultra-marine mais peut-être que vous
puissiez aussi mettre l'accent et cibler
celle des problématiques que ce soit lié
au risque naturel majeur que ce soit lié
au territoire à la taille du territoire
communal ou aux problématiques
particulières que vous rencontrez sans
oublier c'est important les relations et
la nature des relations que vous pouvez
nourrir avec avec l'État
là encore c'est une des singularités
dans les territoires
ultramarins avec des des problématiques
qu'on peut certes rencontrer sur le
territoire hexagonal mais qui se pose
avec une acuité particulière dans vos
territoires et dans vos communes voilà
j'ai déjà été beaucoup trop long donc je
vous cède sans plus tarder la parole
nous allons commencer peut-être avec
Monsieur masse
présidente de l'Association des communes
et collectivités d'outre-mer
oui et absolument et madame le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur
et c'est vrai que j'ai débuté mon propos
en soulignant qu'elle a des
affections des mères pour leur fonction
et proportionner la confiance générale
de la population envers les élus et
municipaux
en effet vous avez que vous pouvez vous
approcher un petit peu plus du micro
s'il vous plaît merci
un petit peu mieux
et la spécificité des Antilles aussi
c'est souvent internet ça fonctionne un
peu mal
c'est pas toujours évident
est-ce que ça va mieux là
non pas vraiment
je vais essayer de mettre les écouteurs
on va essayer de faire ça rapidement
quelqu'un d'autre qui voilà juste le
temps alors peut-être monsieur monsieur
[Musique]
de votre invitation alors je vais
rapidement vous situer la chapelle de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon elle est
composée de il est composé de deux
communes et d'un conseil territorial sur
une superficie de 240 km² et non sur
trois départements avec une population
de 6000 sans habitants donc on est
surtout certainement l'un des plus petit
territoires d'outre-mer la commune de
Saint-Pierre et le chef-lieu elle compte
5500 habitants et la plus petite des
îles 24 km². donc je suis le maire de
Saint-Pierre depuis le 25 mai 2020 et
j'ai été lu au premier tour des
élections municipales le 15 mars 2020
avec 62% des voix le 15 mars donc on a
attendu deux mois et demi pour pour
prendre des manettes de la mairie à
cause de l'épidémie de conduite le
conseil municipal il est composé de 29
membres 24 dans la majorité et 5 dans
l'opposition je vais tenter de répondre
à quelques interrogations
malheureusement premier voici quelques
réflexions qui me viennent à l'esprit
pour une commune de 5500 habitants je
trouve que le nombre de conseillers
municipaux 29 et trop important trop
important car pour présenter une liste
et trouver 29 candidats 31 avec des
suppléants c'est compliqué cela peut
être un frein à démocratie donc ça
limite le nombre de listes et il est
difficile aussi de garder la motivation
des élus au fil du temps alors que la
question du Corum peut poser des
difficultés à la langue et chez nous on
fait la comparaison avec le Conseil
territoriale qui a beaucoup plus de
compétences il ne compte que 19 élus
face à un conseiller municipal comme je
viens de le dire conseil municipal de
Saint-Pierre
et celui de micronate qui est encore 15
donc il y a pour moi ça n'a pas de sens
quoi c'est trop des lieux d'un côté et
peut-être pas assez de l'autre mais
encore que je dirais que le Conseil
Territorial avec 19 élus et largement
suffisant pour une petite communauté
comme l'un l'autre dans une petite
commune comme la mienne je me suis rendu
compte aussi que le mandat de maire est
une fonction à plein temps et quand je
parle de plein temps je ne parle pas de
35 heures par semaine mais très souvent
de 8 à 9 heures par jour quasiment 7
jours sur 7 et je ne vous dis pas que
des heures passées de soins lorsque vous
rentrez à la maison pour consulter les
dossiers je suis issu du privé parce que
j'étais artisan avant d'être maire mais
je vous dis honnêtement que l'indemnité
de merde n'est pas à la hauteur de cet
investissement je vous rassure je ne
fais pas de la politique ou ce mandat
pour faire de l'argent mais consacrer
autant d'heures pour une indemnité de
3100 euros par mois ce n'est pas la voix
peut se remplir les poches et surtout
pour pour assurer une relève parce qu'il
est évident que lorsque je regarde
autour de moi et que je parle des
adjoints pour éventuellement prendre la
relève à un certain moment
quand ils sont fonctionné ou même dans
le privé ben effectivement lorsqu'il
regarde l'indemnité de maire et qui
aucun intérêt pour eux moi je peux me
permettre parce que j'ai 62 ans et
j'arrive à la retraite mais en tout cas
c'est c'est une vraie question alors je
sais que ma question de l'argent est
souvent tabou en France bon je n'ai
aucun souci avec donc je voulais
absolument relever ce point et je ne
parle pas non plus des indemnités que
perçoivent les adjoints
chez nous en tout cas ça fait un micro
pour 5500 habitants ils touchent 900 €
par mois alors que moi je délègue
beaucoup aux adjoints mais faut
comprendre que Ben effectivement avec
des indemnités si peu élevées il
travaille toujours en plein temps bref
autre sujet le nom cumule des mandats
alors je vais vous dire très honnêtement
pendant toute ma carrière politique et
avant d'être inhumé j'ai plaidé partout
pour le non cumule des mondes je dis
franchement maintenant après 3 ans de
mer quelle erreur pas pour des raisons
financières mais pour une question de
poids politique surtout en outre-mer
alors moi j'ai la chance d'être à la
fois mère et conseiller économique et
social et environnemental
et bien en tant que mère d'outre-mer
d'une petite commune ma casquette de ses
œufs me permet d'ouvrir des portes que
je n'aurais jamais ouvert si je n'étais
que mère cela me permet d'être reçu par
exemple au ministère des outre-mer et
dans les dossiers de la mairie et
décrocher donc automatiquement plus
facilement des subventions et aide de
l'État c'est une réalité et c'est
certainement une occasion de mieux se
faire entendre à mon humble en vie un
parlementaire devrait avoir la
possibilité d'être aussi maire d'une
petite commune de plus cela permettrait
d'en faire des parlementaires ancrés
dans leur dans leur territoire et de ne
pas être parfois hors sol excusez-moi de
ma franchise
je considère que je suis aussi un
terrain et proche des gens de par mon
métier artisan comme je vous le disais
j'étais artisan dans le transport donc
proche de commerçants et et et des
particuliers alors Quentin je constate
que les concitoyens sont de plus en plus
exigeants qu'il manque de patience et
souhaite des réponses souvent immédiates
je ne subis pas de violence de la perte
de mes hommes administrer sauf a pris
une semaine de mandat mais c'était un
petit peu un petit peu logique qui avait
des les adversaires qui l'envers en mer
par contre le poids des réseaux sociaux
si je voudrais insister là dessus
surtout sur un petit territoire comme
comme le mien et parfois pesant et je
pense que c'est moralement très très
difficile avec l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux lorsque l'on fait de la
politique ou surtout lorsqu'on pète
critiquer revenir rapidement au
questionnaire que vous avez fait
parvenir
on parle de la crise d'évocation Congo
et lui en 2020 bon je peux me poser la
question un second mandat
m'intéresse-t-il je dirais franchement
quand ils m'ont dit non tout simplement
parce que ce mandat me prend toute ma
vie comme je l'ai dit avant ce n'est pas
une question de divorce entre mes
inspirations et mes possibilités
d'action et du simple fait que ce mandat
existe de ne faire quasiment que ça
au niveau de la question du taux de
participation vous m'arrêtez si je vais
si je suis trop long ou si je vais pas
dans le bon sens le taux de
participation en tant que c'est eux j'ai
été rapporté il y a un an d'une
contribution sur un ordi ayant pour
thème leur participation démocratique
par contribution avait pour objectif de
réaliser un focus sur cette question
dans les outre-mer donc je pose toujours
vous faire prévenir la marque
contribution mais en gros il s’envir que
le taux de participation lors des
élections territoriales dans nos
outre-mer et plus élevés qu'en métropole
lors des régionales ou cantonales
pourquoi tout simplement parce que nos
élections territoriales sont en quelque
sorte notre élections présidentielles en
nous
les élections municipales sont aussi
très suivies en tout cas chez doigts
Saint-Pierre en mars 2020 par exemple à
Saint-Pierre et malgré
l'annonce du covid du covid et du
confinement dans la journée la
participation a été de 57% d'habitude ce
taux de participation pour les
municipales tournent autour de 70% comme
en 2014 ou 73% en 2008
la question des difficultés spécifiques
liées à la gestion des communes je vais
vous dire qu'en arrivant à la mairie de
Saint-Pierre j'avais conscience que
l'une des difficultés dans la gestion
des communes étaient l'ingénierie même
si la mairie avait la chance de disposer
d'un bureau d'études celui-ci ne
comportait que deux agents nous avons
doublé ces effectifs on est passé de 4
lorsque vous avez des projets un budget
en santé donc de l'autofinancement et
pouvait prétendre à des aides de l'État
pour voir être indépendant et se reposer
sur un bureau d'études compétent est une
nécessité et franchement un gage
d'efficacité lors de mon dernier
dépassement en métropole j'ai eu une
réunion de travail par exemple sur les
dossiers mairies au ministère des autres
VR la discussion est plus facile lorsque
vous disposez de dossiers ficelés
et pouvait vous prévoir du fait que
votre commune est celle qui est au top
des Outre-mer avec un taux de
autorisation d'engagement de 94% ce taux
exemplaire vous autorise à solliciter
plus d'aide de l'État mais s'il existe
en même de ce bureau d'études qui nous
permet d'être si performant le pouvoir
d'agir des mers enduisent je n'ai pas
l'expérience et ni le recul nécessaire
pour confirmer sa confirmation je dirais
plutôt que l'on change que l'on charge
plutôt la barque des mairies surtout par
l'accroissement des lourdeurs
administratives et le transfert de
diverses compétences je voudrais juste
deux exemples dernièrement où il y a un
an de ça un an et demi de ça il avait un
problème de gestion des ERP à
saint-pierre-et-miquant des
établissements recevant du public qui
était à une compétence mi-état
mycollectivités territoriale la
collectivité territoriale a pris une
délibération et un refiler en quelque
sorte mais la compétence des ERP aux
deux communes
ensuite même chose au niveau de la
préfecture c'était un souci de gestion
des taxis qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a
refilé la gestion des attractions
mairies il y a pas de souci avec ça sauf
que effectivement quand on cherche dans
Black au bout d'un moment ça devient
très compliqué pour les communes et vous
dire un exemple aussi spécial à 5h30
sans de la compétence des communes et
non des départements
il n'y a pas d'intercommunalité logique
parce que les deux communes sont sur
deux îles différents par contre depuis
mon arrivée à la mairie de Saint-Pierre
et celle de Monsieur de Thierry à mairie
de Mika dans le blog nous essayons de
coopérer dans bien les domaines par
exemple pour la formation de nos
pompiers les démarches auprès de l'État
auprès de la collectivité alors question
épineuse du traitement des déchets parce
que le traitement des déchets pour
l'instant ça fait un micro on repose que
sur les deux mairies ce qui est
scandaleux d'ailleurs un rapport de
votre du Sénat a été
sorti en décembre dernier qui justement
souligne se fait qui est inacceptable
au-delà au-delà de l'intercommunalité
je soulignerai là je soulignerai la
bonne santé des relations
la bonne entente plutôt entre les
meilleurs je crois que ça c'est très
important et surtout des relations
intelligentes à mettre en place alors je
parlais avant de formation des pompiers
il y a aussi Saint-Pierre dispose d'une
école de voile donc on envoie aussi
cette école de voile sur miclon quand
c'est quand même des des gestes mais
enfin des coopération qui est à
soulignée et comme je le disais avant
les services à sensites incendie sont de
leurs compétences des communes enfin
pour terminer c'est l'accompagnement de
l'État objectifment objectivement
l'accompagnement de l'État est réel et
les relations préfectures méritent
Saint-Pierre sont bonnes
j'ai instauré à mon arrivée une réunion
mensuelle entre la directrice générale
du service de la mairie et la secrétaire
général de la préfecture cela permet de
faire le point sur tous les dossiers et
de lever tous les mois s'il y en a les
bouquins les blocages au niveau
financier maintenant le soutien aux
investissements de la commune sont à la
hauteur grâce au FEI c'est le fond
exceptionnel exceptionnel
l'investissement FEI qui est à la main
du ministère des outre-mer pour aider
les collectivités pour leur donner un
coup de main alors dans leur
investissement structurant très
honnêtement depuis que je suis arrivé à
la mairie en 2020 tous les ans on a la
chance de pouvoir bénéficier d'une
enveloppe de 2 millions et demi d'euros
ce qui est énorme important pour une
commune de 5500 habitants et comme je
vous l'ai dit avant on utilise ces
crédits on les dépenses on fait des
projets puisqu'on a 94% d'utilisation de
base donc excusez-moi d'avoir été un peu
long mais
en gros quelques éléments que je
souhaitais vous dire pour la commune de
Saint-Pierre
merci
ben avait branché vos écouteurs
il faut enlever votre allumez votre
micro
est-ce que vous m'entendez mieux là ça
va un peu mieux oui merci
ça va un peu mieux oui bonjour à tous
c'est vrai j'ai écouté les collègues
avec attention c'est vrai que les
grandes difficultés que c'est vrai que
moi j'ai une casquette là parce que je
suis le président de l'accident de
victoire
ultramarins les hommes et les dromes
c'est vrai qu'il y a les difficultés
différentes entre Mayotte la Guyane la
Guadeloupe Martinique c'est vrai moi
j'englobe la totalité
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
Nouvelle-Calédonie et tout ça mais ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que
l'exercice de mer et de plus en plus
difficile parce que vous avez qu'on a de
plus en plus de responsabilités l'état
nous a associé beaucoup avec beaucoup de
responsabilités on a les risques pénal
on a entendu un peu récemment et dans
les années passées les maires qui sont
attaqués au sein même du conseil
municipal et par les usagers c'est vrai
que c'est de plus en plus et on a de
moins en moins de vocation et près de la
population une tâche et c'est Pierre
et très compliqué on a de moins en moins
des moyens financiers et la population
est de plus en plus exigeante je prends
par exemple sur les jobs sur les
Antilles il manque énormément d'emplois
énormément de logements parce que c'est
très difficile à répondre pour les
raisons de foncier et du coup
d'aménagement c'est très très difficile
pour un meilleur je prends par exemple
le maire de Saint-Laurent du Mahomet à
en Guyane et qui a une démocratie et
démographie pardon galopante et doit
ouvrir si on veut dire une école pour
les par exemple tous les huit mois et
uniquement cette année et c'est loin
d'avoir déjà accueillir 1800 nouveaux
esprit contre 1400 en 2022 vous voyez la
difficulté j'ai eu la chance de visiter
l'ouest de la Guyane et sur le fait du
maouni l'encrement des communes il les
déplacements c'est uniquement plus gros
les enfants pour aller à l'école
uniquement en pirogue et c'est vrai que
il y a beaucoup chaque département
devait et avoir un traitement différent
et c'est vrai que par exemple si je
prends le cas de la Guyane de Mayotte il
y a une population et je dirais une
population officielle par l'INSEE et les
populations dont l'émigration importante
que dans toutes les par exemple les
subventions et également insuffisant par
exemple je prendrai pour la Guyane la
vieille et de 2 millions et 7 pour le
département et simplement le besoin
d'être Saint Laurent de Mahony s'élève à
9 millions d'euros vous voyez et la
différence qui qui a est là-dessus en
plus dans les doms et les drones on a
les dépenses du personnel qui est
spécifique les 40%, ça coûte très cher
et et pour les Mairies et surtout et
j'ai dû aussi j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure la mobilité est
plus c'est vrai que un élu de bordeaux
Pour venir une réunion à Paris c'est
facile nous c'est vrai nous c'est
l'avion le coût est très important on
n'a pas ce que j'appelle souvent il
dépense de mobilité pour la formation
même pour locale le plus souvent les
formations se font ailleurs en métropole
il y a tout ça qu'on doit
avoir et c'est vrai que vous avez que
les tarifs aériens a explosé et c'est ce
dernier sur le territoire
ultra marin c'est pas toujours et c'est
vrai que le collègue disait toujours
aussi il y en manque de générer dans les
communes et des dômes et c'est vrai même
l'État au cm pour pour ses besoins
propres à des difficultés parce que
c'est pas assez attrayant et souvent
c'est trop cher on ne trouve pas
vraiment de s'ingénierie je pense qu'il
faut travailler là-dessus si on veut
vraiment développer et nos communes et
dans les domaines et les hommes c'est
c'est important là-dessus et je dirais
la place des communes et ses relations
avec l'État et bon c'est assez bonne les
relations avec les intercommunalités
sont en généralement bonnes mais comme
je l'ai indiqué dans le questionnaires
nos intercourts regroupent beaucoup
moins de communes qu'en hexagone parce
que c'est vrai que moi je prends le cas
de mygalente on a que trois communes si
c'est beaucoup plus facile et c'est vrai
quand vous prenez l'Ouest et de la
Guyane c'est énormément et de commune et
par exemple un intercours de la Guyane
de l'ouest de la Guyane pour
interrupteur 4 fois plus grand que les
départements de l'île de la et de
l'Île-de-France vous voyez c'est
important et la Guadeloupe et mon
collègue et sans doute il va le dire on
a une doublure parce que c'est
l'archipel et souvent ça se vit pas
comme une archipel moi que je suis
meilleur ami galante pour pouvoir aller
dans une réunion Guadeloupe je dois
prendre le bateau et comme il y a deux
et deux erreurs bien déterminées ces 6
heures du matin que je dois prendre le
bateau pour arriver en Guadeloupe et
même si ma réunion se termine à 10h midi
je dois attendre 17h15 pour retourner
chez nous c'est vraiment il y a pas
cette fusité c'est vrai que on n'agit
pas comme un archipel c'est important je
pense que l'État aussi devait prendre ça
c'est important de le côté HP élastique
et des départements et c'est pour bien
situer et et le contexte que j'ai dit
chaque département d'outre-mer devrait
avoir un traitement différent pour aussi
on peut que vraiment que qu'on puisse
avancer qu'on redonne vous aux jeunes de
reprendre une mairie parce que je veux
dire que ils vont hésiter énormément
parce qu'il y a plus en plus de
responsabilités et moins en moins de
moyens pour accomplir parce que nous on
est le premier rempart comme je dis le
premier repas avec la population la
moindre petite chose qui arrive on vous
envoie le maire et souvent on n'a pas la
solution pour leur donner parce qu'on
n'a pas les moyens c'est vrai je pense
il faut reconnaître et les maires et et
on voit très bien dans les élections et
le pourcentage des électeurs est
beaucoup plus important par rapport chez
moi c'est pratiquement 87% des gens qui
dans une contrairement aux élections ça
veut dire que la population aime son
maire mais souvent que le maire n'a pas
toujours la possibilité et la
possibilité de rendre et les services
devaient faire à sa population c'est
tout ça que je pense qu'il faut qu'on
peut se revoir et remettre vraiment le
meilleur au centre et de décision est
vraiment c'est ce qu'on appelle je dis
souvent ce que j'appelle la démocratie
et
proximative c'est vrai que on est le
plus proche de la population je pense
qu'il faut que les meilleurs vraiment en
statut particulier
si après si je peux intervenir sur autre
chose on peut par exemple par exemple
parce que j'ai pas en général pour les
tous les domaines la cité NAF donne un
avis et en France pour tous et chez nous
c'est un avis conforme ça veut dire il y
a deux fois deux mesures ça veut dire
qu'on fait qu'on fait le plus dès que la
CPD n'est pas d'accord avec avec les
maires c'est rejeté automatiquement et à
métropole il y a qu'un avis et il y a
qu'un avis simplement c'est tout ça
c'est petit displarité qui qui fait
souffrir et qui fait souffrir le
développement des DOM c'est je pense il
faut recentrer je veux dire un peu plus
de pouvoir au niveau des mers et des
départements et des régions et pour pour
les hommes et les hommes
est-ce que vous m'entendez toujours
est-ce que vous attendez
oui pardon excusez non c'est bon c'est
bon merci monsieur le Président on va
rebasculer sur Miquelon Langlade si
Monsieur Franck des cheveux gris nous
entend alors je pense qu'il est au
téléphone
et il est même en visio
bonjour je ne suis pas au téléphone je
vous écoute les religieusement
bonjour à tous
mon ami
homologue et Yannick Cambrai a quand
même été bien complet sur sur
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon en ce qui
concerne miclon si vous voulez on a
quelques spécificités que j'aimerais
évoquer aujourd'hui vous m'entendez bien
oui oui tout à fait
de sa double insularité à mi-clan c'est
pareil si vous voulez on est obligé
toujours de passer par le chef-lieu
Saint-Pierre pour pour beaucoup de
choses pour les soins pour les pour les
réunions pour tout et du coup on est
dans ce se trouve très isolé avec une
territoire relativement étendu de plus
de 200 km2 pour 600 habitants et
le bruit dans mon casque
micro qui doit être allumé
monsieur masse peut-être aussi vous
pouviez éteindre votre micro
voilà parfait merci
donc oui on est très isolé et je dois
dire que le mandat de merde sur miclon
Langlade à de moins en moins de succès
juste pour info en 2020 il n'y avait pas
de liste on n'hésite pas à micro-ondes
donc il y a plusieurs mois qui se sont
écoulés et au mois de septembre la
commune risquée de fusionner avec celle
de Saint-Pierre et donc disparaître et
pourquoi je me retrouve actuellement
avec une équipe de 11 conseillers à la
tête de la commune 11 plutôt que 15
parce qu'on n'a pas réussi à l'époque à
combler justement à cette liste donc
c'est vous dire un petit peu les
difficultés que l'on rencontre ici pour
trouver des gens qui veuillent bien
s'investir en politique et servir la
population malgré l'importance que cela
revêt sur une commune aussi isolée que
la nôtre et sur laquelle il faut bien
souvent parler un peu plus fort que les
autres pour se faire entendre ce qui est
ce qui est bien normal
nous sommes peu nombreux et isolés donc
du coup nous avons été élus en septembre
et depuis je dois dire que j'ai été
malgré que je m'y attendais j'étais
largement surpris par l'étendue du
chantier qui m'attendait avec mon équipe
parce qu'il y a quand même énormément de
sujets et très peu de moyens à la
commune de Miquelon Langlade
je n'ai pas tabou non plus dans le
mettre Saint-Pierre au niveau du de
l'argent donc déjà je parlerai de
l'indemnité du maire et des adjoints
donc les adjoints c'est les mêmes que
que Saint-Pierre concernant le maire moi
je suis à 1900 euros ça a été augmenté
de 300 euros pendant ce mandat
inutile de vous dire grâce à Pierre et
miclon avec une Paris indemnité il est
impossible de d'être mère à temps plein
je dois donc cumuler d'autres activités
en parallèle et ce qui ne me facilite
pas du tout la tâche
je pense qu'il y aurait un gros effort à
faire justement pour les petites
communes et pour les mers justement qui
nécessitent de passer du temps pour leur
mandat de faciliter la chose auprès de
des employeurs il faudrait qu'ils
employeurs et des facilités ou des
moyens de nous libérer plus facilement
parce qu'aujourd'hui moi j'ai beaucoup
de beaucoup de difficultés à me libérer
et malgré mes ma grosse responsabilité
de petites communes qui est en lien
direct bien souvent avec les ministères
parisiens et une préfecture un sénateur
on a un député donc et la collectivité
territoriale ça demande énormément de
temps on a un projet phare aujourd'hui
de déplacement de village qui est
quasiment unique en France et pour
lequel je m'investis énormément donc de
ce côté là il y a quand même un effort à
faire je rejoins aussi une à
Saint-Pierre sur le nombre d'élus qui
est trop important je pense que des
petites communes de 600 ans lorsque vous
avez une dizaine d'élus c'est suffisant
pour administrer la commune
donc le cumul des mandats je le rejoins
aussi c'est la même chose je pense que
dans les petites communes on devrait
pouvoir accumuler des mandats
contrairement à Yannick Cambrai je n'ai
pas de mandat j'ai un mandat mais de
conseiller de territorial mais qui ne me
donne quasiment rien de plus que
l'indemnité que j'ai actuellement d'où
la conservation de mon emploi chez EDF
pour votre information malgré quand on
parle de bois justement nationale qui
ont des gros gros moyens
voilà j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés à me faire remplacer pour
[Musique]
apprendre du temps pour en mairie au
niveau de mon travail
donc la mairie de c'est pareil on arrive
on va un soutien de l'État conséquent je
dirais au niveau des investissements on
arrive à décrocher des subventions
régulièrement le problème c'est
contrairement à mon homologue de
Saint-Pierre je n'ai pas justement accès
à de l'ingénierie au niveau de ma
commune ce qui me pose beaucoup de
problèmes aujourd'hui
pour monter des marchés publics auxquels
on est assujetti et ces marchés qui sont
très très lourds réglementairement on a
réussi à obtenir malgré tout une petite
a du
ministère d'outre-mer pour engager un
privé qui nous réalise des prestations
justement de l'assistance sans mettre
d'ouvrage mais ce n'est pas suffisant on
a aussi fait appel à des injuristes donc
un avocat pour aider la mairie dans les
dans ces différentes obligations et
responsabilités parce que bon au-delà de
l'indemnité qui nous permet pas d'en
vivre je tiens quand même à rappeler
qu'on peut être appelé à n'importe quel
moment à la barre donc on est
responsable pénalement et ça aussi à mon
avis ça a un coup aujourd'hui et pour si
on veut attirer des jeunes et on doit
pouvoir aujourd'hui leur assurer
une défense prénom et surtout une
rétribution qui va avec les risques
concours le médecin pierre parler de la
responsabilité des ERP que la
collectivité territoriale avait donné
aux communes d'ailleurs Manu militarisme
sans qu'on donne notre accord moi je
voudrais parler plus largement
aujourd'hui de la vasalité de la
collectivité territoriale sur nos deux
communes qui est naturellement plus
prégnante sur mi-clan parce que la
collectivité territoriale le siège se
trouve sur Saint-Pierre donc loin des
yeux loin du cœur de la mairie de
Miquelon aujourd'hui a beaucoup de mal à
se rendre compte auprès de la
collectivité on est une nous sommes deux
communes des rares communes de
métropoles on peut maîtriser le foncier
et l'urbanisme sur notre commune ce qui
est très très compliqué
on a aujourd'hui on subit moi je subis
sur ma commune des urbanisations sur
certaines zones qui ne sont pas
souhaitées et je n'ai pas mon mois à
dire et lorsque ces zones sont
urbanisées j'ai obligation d'assurer les
services de secours et des personnes et
au bien donc c'est compliqué on est
comme le disait le maire de Saint-Pierre
et les seuls à gérer les déchets sur
l'archipel personne ne s'en occupe non
plus on a quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de problèmes si vous voulez et lorsque
l'on les énumés et qu'on
quand l'évoque sur les réseaux ou sur
les la chaîne le médiocal c'est vrai que
pour attirer les jeunes je ne vous cache
pas qu'on fait mieux
donc c'est vraiment là-dessus que je
voulais je voulais appuyer c'est au
niveau du pouvoir des mers et des
mairies on en a de plus en plus de
normes à respecter avec de moins en
moins de moyens ça devient très
compliqué la responsabilité pénale et
lourde à porter je sais que le maire de
Saint-Pierre d'ailleurs fait
une audition une audition en gendarmerie
pour justement la gestion des déchets
donc il a passé 6 heures quand même en
gendarmerie ce qui n'est vraiment pas
drôle et je le souhaite à personne
aujourd'hui il est temps que l'État
nous entendent et entendre les maires et
lui de proximité par excellence en
Miquelon au malgré le la peur des gens
de s'investir en politique on a eu quand
même plus de 70% des gens qui se sont
déplacés aux urnes donc c'est ça
démontre quand même un certain
attachement à leur mairie contrairement
aux autres élections où les gens se
déplacent peu
donc la collectivité territoriale et la
mairie ICI c'est vraiment les
gouvernements locaux qui font dépasser
les gens aux urnes et on doit les garder
on doit écouter justement la population
et leur intérêt pour pour certaines
strates d'élus qui aujourd'hui font leur
quotidien monsieur maste disait et
Yannick Cambrai aussi lorsque le moindre
problème que vous avez les gens enfin
normalement entre l'ensemble des
compétences qui qui sont à louer aux
élus et bien souvent voilà le seul qui
vient de voir en général c'est leur mère
qui n'a malheureusement pas toujours les
moyens ou les réponses à apporter à
leurs besoins et ça c'est un sentiment
aussi qui est un peu un peu difficile à
vivre même au niveau des compétences si
je prends l'incompétence de la mairie de
Miquelon malheureusement nous n'avons
pas d'intercommunalité et pourtant nous
avons récupéré la compétence germapiti
inutile de vous dire que les dizaines de
kilomètres de dunes que nous avons ici
est d'érosion maritime la mairie de
Miquelon ne peut pas faire face à ces
problématiques c'est impossible mais
aujourd'hui juridiquement c'est bien
nous qu'elle revient donc ça je peux
comprendre que certaines mesures étaient
des prises par rapport à
l'intergoninalité en métropole et des
strates de population beaucoup plus
importantes mais aujourd'hui les
communes d'outre-mer doivent aussi être
pris en compte et ma petite commune
aujourd'hui subit deux plein fouet ces
décisions législatives et c'est très
compliqué on risque à court terme de
disparaître moi je suis dans le même
optique que le médecin pierre a mis mon
dos je pense très sincèrement que je ne
me représenterai pas je suis dans les
55% de votre
de votre questionnaire me dire que je ne
représenterai pas parce que c'est trop
lourd et ça prend ça prend toute ma vie
ça prend aussi une une part une grosse
femme dans vie privée parce que on a
aussi dans des petites communes comme
l'un nôtre on est confronté aux
gens partout où on va on a les réseaux
sociaux qui sont très premium ici on a
très mal vécu mais moi on peut en tous
les cas j'ai très très mal vécu la
période de covid qui a été très tendu
dans notre archipel dans les petites
communautés comme l'un nôtre avec des
confinements des vaccinations
obligatoires lesquelles que nous avons
dû assumer bien évidemment en tant que
mère responsable politique de politique
publique et de santé publique on ne
pouvait pas passer à côté on passer
outre ça moi aujourd'hui je le vis
encore
[Musique]
je vais encore mal mes administrés
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'entre eux
ne souhaitent plus un réservarole à
cause de mesures qui ont été prises par
l'État une époque qui aujourd'hui pour
rappel ont disparu mais la Rencurel n'a
pas disparu et
ça ne donne pas envie de continuer la
politique que je peux vous le dire alors
voilà c'est un petit peu le cri du coeur
un petit peu l'envie de que j'avais
aujourd'hui de vous faire part de de ma
vision des choses pour pour le maire qui
aujourd'hui voilà je le répète manque de
moyens à de plus en plus de normes et de
compétences à assumer et malheureusement
je pense que les mairies n'ont pas fini
de disparaître les mairies ultramarines
et métropolitaine n'ont pas fini de
disparaître par l'absence de mère dans
les années qui viennent je vous remercie
merci merci beaucoup à vous pour ce
témoignage on va passer on va revenir en
Guadeloupe avec Monsieur
Eric André qui est maire de la commune
de vieux fort
Monsieur le Maire
oui vous m'attendez parfait
d'abord pour vous dire bonjour et puis
merci
de nous permettre quand même de nous
entendre tout au moins sur notre
fonction de main je représente la même
au pied levé le président du de
l'association de Guadeloupe qui est
actuellement dans un avion qui n'a pas
pu
participer à cette réunion mais c'est
avec plaisir donc je peux quand même
vous donner quelques éléments à ma
possession ma qualité de premier
vice-président de l'Association des
meilleurs on a fait
de quatrième vice-président de la
communauté d'agglo donc je suis c'est
vrai très proche de mes de mes collègues
et surtout ma qualité demain j'ai été
élu en 2020 c'est c'est ma première
manature dans une commune qui est vieux
fort la des plus petites de la
Guadeloupe encore que je n'aime pas
utiliser ce terme petit parce que bon
quand nous avons des difficultés nous en
avons nous avons les mêmes difficultés
que les grandes communes et nous avons
justement paradoxalement moins de
possibilités à les régler donc le thème
petite commune quelquefois ça ne me va
pas beaucoup et puis bon je dirais que
de manière globale j'ai entendu les
collègues
dire quasiment tout ce que moi aussi je
ressens et que nous ce temps nous aussi
en Guadeloupe par rapport à aux
difficultés de nos communes je dirais
que la dernière
expérience douloureuse que nous avons
vécu c'est tout simplement les aléas
climatiques avec
la tempête tropicale Fiona jusqu'à
aujourd'hui nos communes sont démontées
nos varient sont cassés
les cabinets d'études ont fait le
travail nous n'avons pas la possibilité
d'avancer pour pouvoir
investir et faire démarrer des projets
de réparation donc c'est un travail que
nous faisons actuellement avec le
département et la région malgré
l'expertise qui nous a été mise en place
donc c'est vraiment difficile et moi au
niveau de vieux fort
dans ma commune il y a un port de pêche
avec des marins qui se retrouvent depuis
déjà quasiment trois mois un grosses
difficultés pour exercer leur activité
ce n'est pas simple je dirais que pour
des nous qui sommes des représentants de
l'État les premiers d'ailleurs c'est une
somme à la base de la représentation de
l'État ben il nous faudrait voir dans
quelle mesure nous pouvons avoir aussi
de la part de l'état des moyens
supplémentaires pour que cette
représentation de l'État puisse
véritablement être au service de la
population puisque je le répète les les
services publics nous avons du mal à les
assumer parce que nous n'avons pas
beaucoup de moyens je reviendrai
toujours à je prenais toujours la
référence de ma petite commune quand je
suis arrivé ben je suis j'ai trouvé
une situation difficile avec juste après
mon arrivée donc le départ forcé pour
des raisons de santé du DGS et de DGS
dans une commune comme la nôtre comme la
petite commune c'est lui la
c'est lui la
représentation l'organisation centrale
tourne autour de lui et quand on ne l'a
pas c'est difficile quand on arrive et
qu'on est jeté rapidement dans une
situation qui fait que finalement j'ai
dû jouer pendant une année et demi il
est revenu ça fait ça fait à peine deux
mois pendant plus d'une année et demi
j'ai fait la fonction de meilleur j'ai
exercé la fonction de maigre aussi celle
de DGS
donc ce n'est pas simple de pouvoir
gérer ces choses là et puis je dirais
aussi que cette fonction à temps plein
forcément demande des sacrifices
ailleurs comme on l'a dit le collègue de
ses de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon ben
c'est ma famille qui qui appartient
c'est l'accélération de de mon dossier
de retraite qui fait que bon depuis
septembre 2021 j'ai pas été obligé mais
presque de partir à la retraite ce sont
ce sont des choses qui qui aussi doivent
être prises en compte dans cette
fonction de merde alors en Guadeloupe on
ne peut pas dire qu'il y a pas de
vocation bon le collègue de ces périple
et le sucre Cambri aussi
[Musique]
nous nous avons à Guadeloupe
confirmation qu'on peut penser malgré le
discrédit qui tombe sur les élus nous
avons au niveau des candidatures
sélections municipales
même les élections régionales les
élections cantonales Jean-Claude Maes va
pouvoir le confirmer nous avons toujours
des candidats il y a pas on ne peut pas
dire qu'on a pas de candidat dans ces
différentes échéances électorales nous
en avons beaucoup après c'est tout
simplement la difficulté pour ces
candidats de rendre à la population qui
leur a fait confiance les services de
leur apporter les services qu'ils
avaient qu'ils avaient souhaité avoir
par notre représentation pour notre
élection donc la grosse difficulté comme
je le dis c'est tout simplement que
l'expression des besoins
dans les territoires qui remonte par les
maires me paraît être une grosse
difficulté quand il n'y a pas en face
des possibilités de porter des moyens
pour pouvoir
porter une réponse à ses besoins qui
soient exprimés et ça c'est une grosse
question ensuite après on a évoqué aussi
la situation des communes qui n'ont pas
de cadre dans dans ma petite commune
petite entre Guille je n'ai aucun cadre
c'est encore une nouvelle fois le DGS
qui qui joue ce rôle là or nous avons
actuellement beaucoup de difficultés à
monter des dossiers dans la mesure il ne
suffit pas d'exprimer un besoin de
l'écrire ou de donner une justification
il faut monter un dossier à dossier qui
traite technique qui nécessite forcément
une technicité dans chez la personne qui
montre le dossier nous ne l'avons pas
dans les petites communes il nous manque
des cadres et malgré les efforts qui
sont faits je ne peux pas dire que les
efforts ne sont pas faits puisque au
niveau de l'Association des maires de
Guadeloupe nous avons quand même eu des
contacts avec le ministère de
l'Outre-mer pour évoquer le problème il
y a eu quand même quelques petites
avancées mais les appels à projets on ne
peut pas forcément toujours y répondre
parce que tout simplement nous n'avons
pas la possibilité nous avons pas la
capacité l'expertise pour pouvoir
répondre à ces projets à ses appels à
projets
donc là c'est une bonne question aussi
le ministre de l'autre effectivement a
promis de à côté des appels à projets de
mettre une possibilité pour des dossiers
qui ne soient pas expertisé par des
cabinets puissent être plus en compte et
nous donner la possibilité d'être
entendu reconnu et surtout qu'on puisse
avoir des activités des actions sur nos
territoires mais ça c'est ce n'est pas
encore véritablement lancé alors je
dirais aussi qu'il faut savoir
que plus les deux tiers plus les deux
tiers d'ailleurs des communes de notre
département de Guadeloupe en difficulté
financière
ça on le sait
en face il y a le dispositif quorum qui
depuis quelques temps
nous en avons eu obtenu 4 sous les trois
autres qui étaient donc on a une petite
dizaine de ce dispositif qui viennent
aider les communes mais c'est vraiment
des communes qui sont dans l'urgence
alors que d'autres peuvent aussi
prétendre contenu de leurs difficultés
sont peut-être pas dans l'urgence mais
on a besoin donc les accompagnements de
l'État devraient aussi pouvoir
s'organiser même si ce n'est pas un
dispositif pour même si tout le monde ne
répond pas forcément aux conditions
requises là pour être éligible à ce
dispositif mais je pense qu'il y a une
nécessité pour des communes qui ne sont
pas encore dans le rouge mais qui le
seront si elles ne font pas attention et
si elles veulent répondre aux besoins
mais par la population donc c'est une
situation aussi que je souhaite qu'on
soit en mesure de gérer une réflexion
sur laquelle je crois nous devons porter
toute notre attention voilà un petit peu
quelques points que j'ai noté donc je
n'ai pas eu le canevas
pour pouvoir participer à cette réunion
du dîner mais je voudrais leur souligner
que ce discrédit qui est porté à notre
fonction ne doit pas ne doit pas être
accompagné par une incapacité pour le
maire de pouvoir répondre
aux besoins qui sont exprimés sur le
territoire il faut que nous soyons en
mesure d'être aidé dans ce domaine là et
j'avais pour preuve pour ma
personnellement quand je suis arrivé
dans la commune en 2020
les lignes directrices de la gestion
n'étaient pas n'était pas faites c'est
une obligation et là j'ai eu j'ai été
très souvent
j'ai eu les oreilles au niveau de
l'administration préfectorale même si
après pour jeudi sur la qualité de la
relation va pouvoir en parler
heureusement qu'on a eu un sous-préfet
d'arrondissement qui était à notre
écoute de la proximité puisque le chef
de la préfecture le sous-préfet était
juste à côté donc il nous arrivait très
fréquemment de nous rencontrer de nous
appeler d'échanger spécifique et voir
comment nous pouvions nous acquitter de
cette obligation de ligne directrice de
gestion n'avions pas je n'avais pas
comme je vous l'ai dit je prends mon
exemple à moi mais c'est c'est à des
niveaux peut-être différents les grosses
difficultés des communes parce que
certains nombre de communes n'ont pas pu
non plus s'acquitter de cette obligation
des lignes directives de gestion depuis
janvier
et là je suis en train là encore pour
illustrer la situation de quelques
communes
nous avons eu du mal à constituer de
notre obligation de nous acquitter de
l'obligation du plan communal de
sauvegarde le PCS a été une grosse
difficulté pour nous aussi à pouvoir se
mettre en se mettre en forme on n'a pas
eu tous les tous les concours
souhaitables les pompiers sont
difficiles mobilisés
la technicité contenue de notre
situation
géographique avec tous les aléas
climatiques la prise en compte de toutes
ces de toutes ces de toute cette
dimension là
n'a pas pu forcément être relayé
inscrite dans un dossier par des simples
agents communaux fustent-ils responsable
des secours etc donc ce sont des choses
que nous avons eu comme difficulté à
gérer
sur le
de manière générale de manière globale
l'avenir des communes mais la venue des
communes dépendra forcément de ce que
l'État va pouvoir mettre à la
disposition des mers pour pouvoir mettre
de la proximité au niveau de notre
population
c'est à l'État qui nous Institut des
compétences
de les accompagner de des moyens pour
pouvoir les exercer je pense que ça
aussi c'est si on veut qu'effectivement
une commune soit une commune et répondre
véritablement à la nécessité de ce
niveau
administratif de commune il faut que
l'État arrive aussi à s'organiser pour
nous donner les moyens qu'il faut
quant à l'avenir la Venise du mais oui
l'avenir des meilleurs comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure en Guadeloupe
de volonté d'être humain ça c'est chez
nous c'est
il n'y a pas de problème concernant la
chose de démission il y en a pas malgré
les difficultés mais si au bout de
compte
il y a pas forcément les conditions pour
une bonne implication des mères
peut-être petit à petit nous serons dans
la situation de Saint-Pierre microbe qui
vont
qui ne seront pas candidats à leur
succession par la difficulté d'avoir
eu à exercer cette cette fonction-là
donc voilà un petit peu ce club je peux
dire de manière générale dans les
charges peut-être que je porterai
quelques éléments d'information et voilà
tout ce que je peux dire et puis je vous
remercie de votre écoute
merci merci Monsieur le Maire et merci à
tous les quatre je vais laisser la
parole aux rapporteur pour quelques
questions supplémentaires à nos
collègues aussi s'ils ont des questions
à poser
oui moi simplement peut-être simplement
une une question
sur ce que j'évoquais est-ce que
beaucoup ont évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire les rapports avec avec les
services de l'État singulièrement sur la
question de l'ingénierie parce que
finalement c'est vraiment un des points
communs que l'on que l'on rencontre
je le préciser en introduction de de
cette audition on retrouve autant dans
les dans les communes rurales dans
l'Hexagone
que sur l'ensemble des communes et vous
l'avez indiqué à nouveau que c'est un
besoin qui est qui est criant et
j'oserais rajouter le deuxième qui est
la problématique des financements on a
bien compris que sur
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon j'allais dire
vous aviez un accompagnement de l'État
qui était à saluer disons les choses
très clairement mais mais très souvent
pour avoir travaillé notamment sur la
question des comme je l'ai indiqué tout
à l'heure des risques majeurs on voit
que les communes par exemple en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe sont très
souvent exposés au coûte et aux
conséquences de ces risques on a
notamment travaillé sur la mobilisation
des fonds barniers mais aussi pour
réaliser les les équipements
nécessaires dès lors qu'on a connu des
conséquences parfois dramatiques et donc
c'est avoir un petit peu votre votre
retour sur sur ce sujet là et puis
peut-être la relation là aussi un
phénomène qui va qui va grandissant que
certains ont évoqué la relation à la
population
est-ce que alors on a parlé des réseaux
sociaux
mais est-ce que vous avez le le
sentiment alors malgré la participation
et et le fait qu'on a encore la capacité
à mobiliser les citoyens pour
pour participer aux élections
municipales comment vous jugez le lien
finalement et le rapport à la population
est-ce que au-delà des réseaux sociaux
il y a des il y a des sujets de tension
particulière parce que c'est vrai que
c'est
particulièrement un problème qui est
évoqué notamment par les différentes
associations d'élus
[Musique]
pensez bien à ouvrir votre micro
sociaux
on ne peut pas empêcher
l'évolution qui va qui va dans ce sens
là du développement des réseaux sociaux
on en a besoin aussi
sauf que ça accentue ça accentue la
pression s'accentue la pression sur les
élus
c'est de l'expression aujourd'hui la
réponse doit avec les réseaux sociaux
être apporté quasiment le lendemain et
nous
ce n'est pas toujours facile avec toutes
les tout ce que nous tout ce que nous
connaissons déjà comme des vives par
rapport à ces besoins sociaux ça ça
accompagne de critiques ça s'accompagne
aussi de velléité politique électorale
aussi donc je dis que c'est ce sont des
choses aussi que nous avons à gérer et
quand nous n'avons pas de réponse pour
porter assez expressions de besoins nous
sommes dans la difficulté et je crois
que ça c'est un résultat tout simplement
de la difficulté pour nous d'avoir les
moyens de notre tâche des moyens tout
simplement de d'accomplir notre fonction
si nous avions les moyens pour pouvoir
envisager tout de suite de porter des
réponses ou des orientations ou faire
patienter la population je pense que le
problème des réseaux sociaux ne serait
pas un gros souci pour nous à gérer
l'essentiel pour moi comme je dis c'est
tout simplement que nous puissions avoir
déjà des réponses à apporter pas
forcément des réponses dans la
réalisation de tout ce qui nous est
demandé mais des réponses concernant
les
chocs que nous allons faire face à un
problème qui nous exposé que ça soit par
la voie normale par les constats ou bien
par les réseaux sociaux donc je pense
que c'est
qui qui nous manque après
je te le dis oui nous avons l'État c'est
vrai que nous avons l'État avec nous
nous avons des propositions d'aide pour
pour Fiona nous avons et pour enfin
jeunesse c'est tout simplement le
phénomène climatique qui nous a impacté
beaucoup sur dans le sud de la
Guadeloupe et particulièrement de la
commune à Vieux-Fort nous avons eu oui
nous avons eu l'accompagnement de l'État
nous avons eu les aides nous avons eu
des visites vous avez eu des constats on
ne peut pas dire qu'on a pas eu on n'a
pas eu l'accompagnement de l'État
nous avons aussi de très bonnes
relations je pense que ce n'est pas
il faut le dire depuis
trois quatre mandatures de préfet les
préfets ont toujours été très très
oui à côté des élus on n'a pas eu ça bon
les deux derniers encore mieux et c'est
surtout les sous préfet qui on a la
tâche effectivement d'être sur le
terrain et de pouvoir
nous avons nous avons des occasions de
rencontrer d'avoir des sous-préfects qui
participent à nos réunions à nos travaux
quand nous avons des difficultés sous
telles tel sujet ça c'est un élément
comme un qui est important ça donne du
crédit au travail de l'État ça je ne
l'ai pas su aller mais c'est vrai que
nous en Guadeloupe on ne peut pas dire
que l'État n'est pas à nos côtés et vous
avez donc depuis une bonne dizaine
d'années toutes les grosses difficultés
que nous avons eu avec les grosses
grèves du l.a.p ben nous étions moi en
tant que président de la vice président
de l'association des maires en relation
quasiment quotidienne avec avec le
préfet les sous-préfet donc il y a cet
aspect là il faut il faut le dire dans
la proximité dans la relation humaine il
y a des il y a on est sur on est on est
bien voilà
très bien monsieur le Président
peut-être de l'Association des communes
et collectivités d'outre-mer monsieur
masse
sous la Guadeloupe il y a des
spécificités mais ce que je veux dire
par exemple les réseaux sociaux aussi
c'est assez premium pour un meilleur
parce que tout ce qui est fait et
pratiquement sur le réseau social et
c'est vrai qu'on a pas toujours la
possibilité de répondre immédiatement ou
de porter et la solution je le prends le
cas de Mayotte ou de Guyane avec les
sécurités qui a par exemple pour pour la
population pour les écoles je prends le
cas de Mayotte pour pour que les enfants
puissent aller à l'école il fallait
qu'il soit accompagné par les forces
publiques et les meilleurs par mois n'a
pas tout et les moyens pour pouvoir
assurer la sécurité et de ses enfants
mais
soulignation souvent par moins ils sont
complètement dépassés j'étais comme j'ai
dit j'étais en Guyane c'est vrai que ils
sont
[Musique]
mais dans les autres départements que
j'étais Mayotte Guyane et nouvelle
galerie c'est un peu à part il y a des
grosses difficultés et et des maires et
ils sont à peu près comme c'est Pierre
le micro qui il y a certains qui m'ont
dit qu'ils vont pas renouveler et et
leur mandat pour la prochaine et
mandature c'est ça il faut prendre ça et
dans la globalité et des choses
j'ai pas fait je n'ai pas fait gaffe en
vous le disant nous vivons actuellement
une grosse difficulté qui est celle de
porter de trouver une solution enfin une
alternative à au problème des Sargasses
la commune de Monsieur maest d'ailleurs
nous avons les communes qui sont
fortement impactées et ce n'est que très
récemment avec l'État nous avons trouvé
la solution
du givre pour pouvoir mettre en place
réunir un petit peu tout le monde et
voir qu'est-ce qui peut être fait là on
est complètement dépourvu avec
une intersification au plan sanitaire
puisque
tout simplement l'accumulation de ces de
ces algues joue un jour cru des
phénomènes
biologique que nous avons du mal à
assumer donc là aussi c'est vrai que la
difficulté réside dans dans
l'organisation pour les communes qui
fortement impacté il y en a qui ne le
sont pas mais qui sont tout aussi qui ne
sont pas forcément l'abri du fond
n'avons jamais été très impacté mais
nous sommes pas à l'abri puisqu'il y en
a quand même qui entre chez nous que
nous arrivons à gérer ou alors à la
limite qu'on géopard puisque ça n'a pas
été pas de grosses difficultés mais là
aussi voilà des des situations qui font
que finalement les mains d'autres maires
et particulièrement les 6 ou 7 communes
qui sont impactées par les saga c'est ça
on peut dire qu'il y a une très très
grosse difficulté pour l'État d'aider
les communes et donc des délais
population qui sont impactés par cette
pensée ça augasmes de de trouver des
conditions pour pouvoir vivre décemment
et à toute sécurité donc là là c'est une
c'est une très bonne question aussi
alors heureusement que je dis que nous
avons quelquefois aussi les
collectivités
départements et les gens qui suivent des
points précis et dans des dans les cas
d'urgence arrive à mobiliser et arriver
à se mobiliser forcément mobiliser des
fonds financièrement à pouvoir
rapidement en urgence aider les communes
mais c'est vrai que ça ce n'est pas
possible dans tous les domaines pour
Fiona et à une grosse mobilisation qui a
été faite par la région concernant les
problèmes de l'eau on a pas réglé les
problèmes de l'eau au niveau du
département c'est c'est encore malgré la
structure qui a été mise en place mais
c'est une structure qui a été mise en
place sans les moyens pour pouvoir
conduire une politique pour permettre à
tous les mois de l'Open de retrouver de
l'eau dans le robinet là là c'est c'est
une Grenelle inquiétude et ça s'aggrave
de jouer en jeu et ça discrédite
justement la mesure que monsieur le
ministre le Cornu avait engagé avait
réalisé qui était celle de de réunir
autour de la table tous les acteurs et
voir dans quelle mesure il y aurait une
unité au niveau de la de la gestion de
leur Guadeloupe mais quand on a une
structure et qui n'a pas les moyens de
travailler ben c'est comme si on en a
pas et donc les problèmes de l'eau
demeure encore sur demeure de manière
très très très difficile à assumer nous
avons de tout d'eau encore
jusqu'à maintenant ça fait déjà une
bonne vingtaine d'années que ça dure la
création de la structure en septembre
2020 à laquelle j'appartiens ces 20 à
laquelle je suis au niveau du conseil
d'administration mais moi
personnellement je me dis mais qu'est-ce
que je fais là dans la mesure où on n'a
pas les moyens de régler un problème qui
est celui de donner de l'eau à tous les
guadeloupéennes donc de mettre les
moyens pour pouvoir changer les
compteurs pour pouvoir changer les
conduites nous avons eu de grosses de
grandes unités
Veolia général des eaux qui sont qui
sont restés une bonne vingtaine d'années
à exploiter ces réseaux là et puis nous
allons laisser les réseaux à part
entendre dans un état lamentable donc
les les
rustines qui ont été portés par Monsieur
karaoké le ministre il y a pas très
longtemps dans dans les fuites c'est
vraiment
infinités email quoi dans dans les
problèmes à régler donc tout ça aussi
fait que nous les mères mais ça voyager
sur bien même si c'est la compétence a
été dévolue au smgag mais la population
ne va pas voir le CMG mais va voir tout
simplement le maire pourquoi est-ce que
le poisson n'a pas d'où parce qu'on n'a
pas ceci parce qu'on a passé donc cet
élément là aussi c'est à prendre en
compte lorsqu'il y a des phénomènes de
de de l'ampleur des soldes lorsqu'il y a
des difficultés comme celle de l'eau
lorsqu'on a d'autres grosses difficultés
je n'oublie certainement ben nous
n'avons pas nous n'avons pas ce qu'il
nous faudrait pour pouvoir donner du
crédit à la fonction de même et
véritablement nous permettre
d'intervenir nous permettre d'être au
côté de la population les représenter et
trouver des solutions à leurs problèmes
merci pour conclure peut-être
une femme qui était meilleur avant moi
et la démissionné à cause de sa base
parce qu'il avait pas il avait pas la
porte et de l'État et il a dit
démissionner parce que depuis 2011 on
est envahi par les sardase il y avait
pas de réponse et toute la charge était
sur la commune et elle était tellement
désabusé que c'est pas représenté ça
veut dire et c'est vrai que il y a aussi
des administrations que je le dis j'ai
pas mal responsabilité qui est trop
poignante la DL par exemple pour faire
quelque chose il y a toujours des
contraintes très forts qui consulte pas
le maire et un certain moment la
population ne comprennent pas en ce
moment pourquoi quelque chose aussi
longtemps avant de réagir et comme on le
dit le maire est prêté à l'index ça veut
dire on est des incompétents on peut pas
faire même qu'on explique il dit que
c'est le mieux c'est que vous êtes
capable de faire en ces moments se
trouve il faut avoir un peu de souplesse
et avec les organismes comme la vieille
pour par exemple pour les permis
les traits de porte il y a des choses
qu'on vit sous la territoire qu'on
maîtrise mieux que et que qui ne
viennent pas nous consulter assez
souvent pour trouver une solution
commune merci pour terminer peut-être
rapidement parce qu'on a dépassé un
petit peu le temps qui nous est imparti
monsieur Cambrai ou pour cette relation
avec les
citoyens par le biais aussi des réseaux
sociaux et la pression qu'on peut avoir
sur sur aujourd'hui des nouvelles
pratiques de communication
dans mon propos que c'était un souci
mais après ça il faut pas non plus tout
dramatiser moi je vais vous dire
franchement après avoir été élu au
conseil de nettoyeur pendant 11 ans dans
l'opposition après avoir été conseillé
municipal pendant de longues années
actuellement conseiller économique et
social je peux vous dire que le mandat
de mai est le plus beau je crois que
c'est le plus beau que que peut offrir
la République parce que c'est vraiment
celui où vous êtes en contact avec la
population vous pouvez agir sur votre
quotidien et effectivement quand vous
avez à la fois une bonne gestion de
votre budget une situation saine des
aides qui arrivent et quand je l'ai dit
avant pour pallier au problème
d'ingénierie un bureau d'études alors ça
coûte quand vous avez quatre employés
mais je pense que c'est c'est vraiment
la solution pour répondre aux besoins
des investissements des communes en tout
cas moi je le pratique ainsi et je peux
vous dire que les résultats sont trop
bons sont pour autant me vantés parce
que comme je vous l'ai dit alors si je
repartons pour faire un deuxième mandat
je leur ai annoncé dès que j'ai été élu
j'étais là pour un mont d'or parce que à
mon âge il faut aussi penser aux autres
mais j'avais jamais cru que c'était
aussi prenant en tout cas c'est pas très
très beau mandat et ça je tenais à le en
témoigner et le souligner
merci bien et ben écoutez merci
messieurs on va vous libérer merci de
nous avoir consacré un peu de votre
temps précieux pour pour témoigner et ça
sera pour nous très important pour la
rédaction finale de notre rapport merci
en tout cas et bonne fin d'après-midi
dans vos beaux territoires au revoir
merci au revoir merci à vous merci à
tous les collègues et à bientôt à
bientôt